so the high value Alpha guys that that
you also find you attraction to how many
of them have you dated have you have you
met many of them or um some have been
not so much um but I'd say most of them
yeah are my ex is the typical you know
Tennessee South Carolina tattoos
motorcycle riding yeah open opened my
car door for 12 years you know okay well
he sounds like an awesome guy what
happened to the marriage why did it end
it my fault
I had enough hair oh no yeah so he drew
a line in the sand so if he was such a
good guy why did you step out on him
hold
on um I don't
know did you get bored yes why did you
get bored if he's doing everything you
want opening the car door he's got the
tattoos he rides a motorcycle he's
successful he's a southern guy I don't
know midlife crisis that's what my
friends say right was it worth
it probably
not do you wish that you were back with
him well he still wants me to and I'm
not I'm just not I'm just still not
there I'm just
not but I know I'm going to regret it I
know it's gonna like hit me like a ton
of bricks and I'm gonna regret it what
Happ you you stepped out on him and he
wants to reconcile and and you don't
would do anything for me to be back no
don't so you guys have kids together
though to be with him but I just don't
want to be with him I don't know why it
just like I just like fell out of love
like completely and what happened to the
guy that you had the affair
with
[Music]
um that didn't really work
either because I mean like you must have
thought that that it was going to go
somewhere like you were were hoping that
it was going to go somewhere but it just
didn't so
yeah was he married did he just end it
like what happened younger I just once
it was not um forbidden anymore thought
I kind
of I think it was hotter when it was
forbidden okay so you wanted some
excitement the
thrill so you were born it sounds like
in your marriage and your
relationship all my friends are like
midlife crisis I'm like did you like why
did you do it if you thought like I'm
guessing thought that he was going to be
upset right like you didn't have an open
relationship it was it was unknown to
him it was a surprise correct how did he
find out I finally just told him I I
just couldn't do it anymore I just I was
getting real sloppy uhuh I just got to
the point where I was like like we had
our location you know we share locations
and I would just turn it off be like why
I'm like oh I don't know I'm out I can't
turn it back on I don't know how bye
like right I was just getting real
sloppy and bad
yeah what would you do different if you
go back in a time
machine I couldn't tell you because I
don't know if I can make myself feel
that way about him anymore I don't know
I don't know why there's nothing wrong
with him he's like perfect attractive
everything okay so let me ask you this
question because there's this no notion
that I talk about in my book called beta
tization through a thousand concessions
and for those people that have read my
book and know what I'm talking about if
you know you know if you don't let me
take a moment to explain um women will
beta tize men women will beta tize all
men in a long-term relationship or a
marriage it's it's not a question of if
it's to the extent of how much right so
the guys so it looks something like this
hey honey you know don't brush your
teeth over there you're going to get
toothpaste on the carpet honey um you
know put the white socks in the white
hamper and the dark socks in a dark
hamper honey let's go vegan together
honey let's do this and it's like the
guy goes through this process of making
concessions one after the other with a
stamp I don't know if you ever watch any
standup comedy but there's a routine
that uh I think it's Chris Rock does
he's like just say yes yes yes yes yes
and he just stamps everything yes right
as you as you go through this process as
a guy just agreeing to everything not
able to say no to her she starts to lose
attraction to you right because he
becomes a yes man yes yeah I think
that's what it is he became so like
engulfed in me so he did did exactly
what he was told to do he took vows and
sickness and health and better for worse
uh rich or poor blah blah blah said yes
to everything you asked him to do was a
good-look guy was I'm guessing he he
took care of things paid the bills there
was no issues with money we struggled
for a little while but we haven't the
last few years okay so what was more
attractive about the guy that you had
the affair
with the forbiddenness I think that's
like literally it see I don't think that
a lot of women understand that this
happens they're oblivious to it you know
for the most part but they don't intend
to make the guy unattractive it's just
that I think it's in women's nature to
always test a man right they want to
know that he's competent they want to
know that he can get things done
anything I said anything and everything
and I think over time it got like
annoying to me right which is
interesting isn't it because this is
what most women you know would expect to
want in a marriage or anything like that
you had that and that got boring for you
I for a man like that and you just don't
want him I'm like sorry I don't know
what to do yeah I mean there's there's
0% chance that you can have a respect
for a man that is begging to take you
back after you're the one that stepped
out I mean that's yeah there's just no
way there I mean like I'd be interested
to see like I mean it's it's all
hypothetical my guess is that you would
have some respect back and you would
feel the pull if he was the one pulling
away um but all he's doing is you know
he's a piñata you're kicking the [__]
out of him and all he's doing is pitting
up candy
yeah it's an interesting way to put it I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out